I can't believe I have to do this but I
do there's this meme Democrats are bad
for the deficit Republicans are good for
the deficit the reality of course is
that Republicans often oversee some of
the biggest increases to the deficit
that we have seen in history and the
problem is that many people don't even
understand the basic terms including the
difference between debt and deficit they
sort of used the terms interchangeably
they don't know what the hell they're
talking about or what anybody's talking
about when they talk about these issues
the reality is that President Obama has
drastically reduced the deficit and you
might say but David how is this possible
I've seen the National Debt Clock it's
going up and up and up you're lying that
Obama has reduced the deficit let's see
if we can get on the same page and for
anyone with a seventh grade education
that they remember this clip this part
of I really do apologize that I have to
do this but I do have to do this Louis
that's the reality the national debt is
the total cumulative amount owed by the
federal government of the United States
okay
the national deficit is the federal
government budget balance from year to
year so let's work through an example
together I feel like Sal Khan from Khan
Academy where he talks through these
concepts so so let's imagine we call we
invent a country right called I don't
know the Democratic People's Republic of
Louis okay just for lack of a better
name this sounds like a great place year
one you run a hundred dollar deficit so
after year one your debt is $100 in year
two you reduce the deficit fifty percent
from a hundred dollar deficit to a fifty
dollar deficit that moves your debt to a
hundred and fifty dollars and in year
three Wow again you reduce the deficit
by 50 percent down to only $25 but as
you notice the debt continues to go up
to a hundred and seventy five dollars so
from year one to three you can
accurately say the deficit was reduced
75% but the debt continued to increase I
hope that this illustrates the
difference here so now let's talk about
President Obama the u.s. deficit
is the smallest that has been in eight
years the deficit is the smallest of
President Obama's presidency it is the
lowest since 2007 both in terms of
dollars and as a prince percentage of
GDP in the Obama era the deficit has
shrunk by a trillion dollars and as a
percentage percentage of the economy the
deficit is now down to just 2.5 percent
which is below the average from the last
50 years and down 10 percent from when
President Obama took office now what do
people think about this Louis well a
Bloomberg politics poll found that 73
percent of the public believes the
deficit has gotten bigger over the last
six years the year before the same
pollster found only six percent of
Americans realized that the deficit was
shrinking we should be embarrassed right
yes but you could take this you could
take any number of topics yeah related
to government spending or government or
whatever Dave many people just don't
actually look into this type of stuff as
soon as you get nuanced with them they
check out they're watching Fox News
nuanced yeah here's the definition of
debt and here's the definition of
deficit whoa well you know it is nuanced
because all people think is money right
more money less money there's nothing
else that's all it is it's just money
just like time you should really be
focusing more on this stuff in school
right I mean you should really focus on
you know personal financial knowledge
these issues basic civics we really need
to be teaching this stuff in school
because it's amazing how many people
become adults without the the just most
basic understanding of some of these
concepts people who claim to be well
educated and politically aware or you
could go back even earlier Dave and you
could just say we need to teach critical
thinking you need to teach people how to
analyze anything and everything how to
tax critically how to do research yeah
and I think that that is a valuable
valuable skill set the Texas Board of
Education is against that right